in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Nathan
and Lisa are with us hey guys how are
you hi there welcome where're you guys
from
we're from Yorkville Illinois which is
about an hour from Chicago awesome
welcome to Nashville and you're here to
do your debt-free scream yes I love it I
love it how much have you paid off 30
1942 dollars in 18 months
way to go I'm making what kind of range
of income making 70,000 okay very good
what do y'all do for a living I'm a
paraprofessional for a special education
co-op mm-hmm and I'm a warehouse
supervisor for a distributions Pernod
company very COO what kind of debt was
the 32,000 well a thousand of it was a
credit card $2,000 was a parent loan for
a camper oh yeah and the rest was all
student loans ah Sallie Mae got kicked
out yes the old woman on the street
eviction notice time I love it well
congratulations you two
thank you very very well done how's it
feel to not have any debt so tell me
your story what happened 18 months ago
that made you decide to change your life
well I actually kind of began a little
sooner for me I had read one of your
books a friend of ours had given it to
us and I kind of just started doing it
on my own
not really filing it to a tee mm-hmm and
then our church was doing a class and
she decided to have us go and I was like
I guess I'd already read the book but we
went anyways and yeah that's the best
thing we ever did that was for sure Wow
so Financial Peace University yes and
that kicked it into overdrive 18 months
ago yes actually I wasn't even he's read
the book and I didn't even really know
he did yeah I was actually getting
scared that we weren't saving any money
and so he um he started trying to do all
this stuff and then I kind of convinced
him to not do it as much and then the
financial peace class came out and I was
like hey we should go to this and
it's a great idea darling I love it
so what do you think it was about the
class that you learned or the process or
what was it that changed everything
because you guys are kind of just did he
Bop it along and all sudden it's like
game on baby I mean what what caused
that switch to flip well for me it was
the accountability of having all those
people in the class friends of ours the
dieter dings actually we're leading the
class and so you know we were talking to
them outside of class too and but having
all those people in the class and it's
you know really getting into it and
being us both being on the same page was
huge because when we were both kind of
going our own separate directions kind
of fighting each other yeah yeah it
didn't work out how long have you guys
been married eight years okay have you
ever been dead free while you were
married until now nope I'm very proud of
you white again excellent excellent
excellent job and so you got your kiddos
with you yes yep all right and what are
their names and ages we have Marissa who
is six Claire will be four in two weeks
and then Owen is 20 months ah fine very
cool
mr. Owen is in charge of the house right
now yeah that's that's very cool weather
good-looking family congratulations yes
well we're gonna give you a copy of
Chris Hogan's signed book number one
bestseller retire inspired because
that's the next stage for you yeah now
that you're out of debt now you can
build wealth and increase your
generosity and increase your change your
whole family tree I'm looking at three
future millionaires right here you guys
stay on track you make enough money and
you've learned how to handle money you
learn how to work together there's no
reason you shouldn't be especially as
young as you guys are well
congratulations thank you
very well done have the kids been
practicing see how that worked out all
right Nathan and Lisa from the Chicago
area with Marissa Claire and Owen
$32,000 paid off in 18 months making 70
a year count it down let's hear a debt
free scream ready three two one weird
I love it very very well done that's how
you do it that's how you do it right
there man that's great stuff hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show you can
do this you know that really is a
message whether you've got two hundred
seventy thousand dollars in student loan
debt or 27 thousand well you've got a
fifty thousand dollar income or $500,000
in the common